ίτο πρόβλημα είναι ότι δε θαίνεται να υπάρχει το αντίπαλοδές ι άλλη πρόταση υπάρχει ανγκή
παμε και πι για το βόλτααλλά υπάρχει ανάγκη για τη δημιουργία ενώς κόμματος που να
είναι στην αριστερα βλέποντας αυτά πο κανα της εκατο θεωρώ ότι το ακέλ ακόμα έχει
ανθρώπους κορυφέα στελέχει που λένει ότι είναι κομονιστικών κόμμα ρα αν ακόμα πιστεύεις ότι μπορείς
ναφέρεις των κομουνισμό όσοσι διολογεία ως πολίτευμα ος ος τρόπος διαχείρησης των πραγματων σε βαστών
και στην ελλάδα ντοκούκου ε υπάρχει και μάλιστε να ρκετα σεβαστών το ποσωστό του αλλά
δε βλέπει κανένας το κουκου έ στην ελλάδα και ν λέει μάλιστα μια μέρα θα
γίνουν κυβέρνηση θα είναι μια ζωή κόμμα δι αμαρτηρίας άρα αν το ακελ οδεβει προς
τα εκεί ναι η αριστερα ή ημίδεξιά την πούμε έτη ι άλλη άποψης χρειάζεται μια
έκραση σίγουρα υπάμε για τον συναγερμό για τα ονόματα ακούγονται ανδρ απιστέρεισε ότι την επόμενη
τον βουλεκτικών αντα αποσωστά του συναγερμού δεν κινηθούν στα επίπεδα που περιμένει ο κόσμος τα
κό αστελέχει του κόμματος περιμένουν κάποιες στη γωνιά ντηναν ήταν δημητρί τάξι κοίταξε στην πολιτική
πάντα κάποιος σε περιμένει στη γνιά τώραναένας ανδύο νδέκα πόσες ενηγωνίας εξαρτάτε που το εκλογικών
αποτέλεσμα αλλά το θέμα ν εδώ είναι στις τελευταίες εκλογιές που ήτανδιπλές υροεκλογές και δημοτικές
εκλογίς ο συναγερμός επαθεν πώσύντερα στη απτ μεγάλη πτώ συναμένει μευπευργολικός πολύ μεγαλεπτώσεις τα εκλογικά
του ποσοστά τις ευροεκλογίές νομίζω ότι έπαθεν ένα μεγάλον πατατράξι τις δημοτικές εκλοίς εκεί ήτανμε
μεγάλες ιας τοχίες που έγινεκαι ο συναγερμός επέλεξε λίγο όπως το αγέλ με τι διακυβέρνηση
χριστόφεια ναδιαλέξει το καλόν σενάριο το καλόν αφύγημα παραμένουμε πρώότη δύναμη